sixteen of the world's airlines on the
threshold of the supersonic age
customers for the anglo-french conquered
the first supersonic airliner in the
world in 1969 time and space collapsed
when mance lose the disguise at 1300
miles per hour and then it suddenly
ended the Concorde flew off into the
sunset today ending at least for now the
era of supersonic passenger travel
really unique in the history of
technology is to have a capability and
then lose it now this technological
marvel is on its way back
we're in Styria new progress and air
travel my long-term mission of boom is
to make that happen
[Music]
today man is planning for the
development of a supersonic transport
back in the 1960s the future of flight
was supposed to be supersonic a
commercial airliner that will cruise at
speeds up to 2,000 miles per hour when
the Concorde made its commercial debut
in 1976 it was an engineering marvel
that represented the technological
promise of the 20th century the first
Concorde swooped down out of a bright
sunshine sky like some prehistoric bird
of prey but twenty seven years after its
initial flight the Concorde landed for
the final time ending the era of
civilian supersonic travel so why did
the airliner of the future become a
museum artifact first airplane came from
bicycle entrepreneurs the first
practical airliner the dc-3 was created
by founder led company and they had to
produce aircraft that made economic
sense
Blake shoal is the founder and CEO of an
aviation startup called boon technology
that's trying to revive supersonic air
travel but with SuperSonics we changed
that and instead of building an airplane
that made sense we'd build airplanes for
national prestige Concorde was always a
state-funded white elephant
so when cost went up and ticket sales
dropped the French and British
governments were backing the venture
decided to pull out another factor that
hobbled the evolution of supersonic
flight was an overland speed limit
imposed in both the US and Europe the
speed ban was pushed by environmental
activists who claimed the bang from
sonic booms would be the loudest noise
ever it would be the equivalent of a
bomb blast to nearby buildings people
talk about a sonic boom and we can't
have sonic booms if that was the case
they would have been a noise limit not a
speed limit 14 years after the Concorde
was grounded private companies are on
the verge of bringing supersonic air
travel back and this time it'll be built
to last
boom technologies aircrafts will mainly
fly over water and the company has
devised a new form factor a three engine
jet that can carry up to 55 passengers
and fly is more than twice the speed of
sound cutting transatlantic travel times
nearly in half and while a ticket for
the Concorde would originally set you
back about 15 grand in today's dollars
Blum expects to charge five thousand
dollars round-trip from London to New
York on board it's definitely more
comfortable than Concorde so it'll be
like flying first-class domestic in the
u.s. less wide seed trade table and my
personal favorite feature is a cup
holder that is nowhere close to where
you put your laptop Bloom is taking
advantage of the variety of innovations
that have come along in the last 50
years Concorde was designed in wind
tunnels where each iteration takes about
six months and therefore you just can't
test many ideas and today you can do all
your aerodynamic development and
software simulation which means that for
almost no money
you can test thousands of ideas conquers
an aluminum aircraft limited heat
capability limited ability to form it to
the shape you want and today we have
carbon-fiber composites the same stuff
that's flying on a Boeing 787 or Airbus
350 and that lets you build a strong
lightweight structure that's any shape
you want which is really important for
SuperSonics because the ideal design of
a supersonic airplane has virtually no
straight lines on its a patchwork of
flowing beautiful curving surfaces
Concorde famously was the only passenger
airplane to ever fly with an afterburner
and if your airplane geek like I am with
AK Roberto should just the coolest thing
that their flame come out the back of
the engine they're loud they turn heads
but if you're an airline you hate them
because the flame scares passengers and
the noise causes people to call their
congressman and last but not least
they're incredibly fuel inefficient and
today we have something called a
turbofan the same kind of engine
technology that's on other commercial
aircraft and effectively what we're
doing at boom is adapting it to
supersonic flight
boom isn't alone in its quest to speed
up air travel it has several private
competitors and NASA is working with the
engineering firm Lockheed Martin to come
up with its own version of a supersonic
plane shull says it's a waste of money
we're building a small supersonic
demonstrator aircraft that's going to
cost us less than thirty million dollars
NASA is paying Lockheed will be close I
think to three hundred million dollars
to do essentially the same thing so
private industry is able to do this
roughly an order of magnitude cheaper
than government and also without
requiring any taxpayer money current
regulations will prevent companies like
boom from offering supersonic flights
between California and New York before
they can enter that market the FAA would
to overturn its ban on overland travel
reverse that and now New York to San
Francisco could be 2 hours and 20
minutes
boom revealed their design for the xbone
demonstrator jet last November and is
working with Richard Branson's Virgin
Galactic's build and test the prototype
in 2017 we're fans of speeds we're doing
this as quickly as possible so that
first airplane the xt-1
supersonic demonstrator will fly in
about a year and after that we know that
all the technology works and materials
are working their dynamics are what we
need them to be blake hopes out of
supersonic flight can catch on with
business travelers market forces will do
their work by improving technology and
bringing down costs making supersonic
flight accessible to the masses the
state-of-the-art for how airlines
compete today is a fly our airplane
we've got a great lounge and that better
champagne but nobody wants a longer
flight everyone want to get there at
half the time and this is a chance for
airlines to make it significantly more
faster
you
[Music]